[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Mittwoch Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport
aus Syrien und der Türkei werden immer
mehr Opfer gemeldet
Land unter Schock in der Türkei wächst
die Kritik an unzureichender Hilfe die
Zahl der Toten im Erdbebengebiet steigt
auf mehr als 11.000
silensky in Westeuropa London verspricht
Kampfjet Ausbildung für ukrainische
Piloten in Paris trifft er am Abend den
Bundeskanzler und Präsident macron
und Gold für Norwegen der
Titelverteidiger gewinnt zum Auftakt der
Biathlon WM in Oberhof die Mixed-Staffel
Team Deutschland enttäuscht
es ist ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit und
gegen die Kälte in den Erdbebengebieten
zählt jede Stunde um noch Überlebende
aus den Trümmern zu bergen ein Foto aus
der Türkei ging heute als Symbol für die
Katastrophe um die Welt
ein Mann hält die Hand seiner toten
Tochter die 15-Jährige liegt unter
Trümmern begraben für sie kommt jede
Hilfe zu spät sie ist eines von
inzwischen mehr als 11.000 bestätigten
Todesopfern in der Türkei und in Syrien
dazu kommen mindestens
53.000 verletzte allein in der Türkei
hunderttausende sind obdachlos was das
bedeutet hat unsere reporterin Anne
Brühl in elbistan erlebt Lena
sünderbruch fasst ihre Bilder zusammen
eine Frau im Arm ihres Bruders die
beiden stehen vor den Trümmern ihres
Hauses darunter verschüttet liegt ihr
Ehemann der Vater ihrer zwei Kinder
gestern hat sie ihn noch gehört doch nun
hat sie die Hoffnung aufgegeben dass er
noch lebt
ich habe niemanden mehr ich bin ganz
allein
ihre Nachbarin Dilek hat 15 bekannte
verloren begraben oder erfroren unter
den Trümmern sie selbst versucht nun bei
Schnee und eisigem Wind unter anderem in
einer Gartenhütte zu überleben wir sind
oft stillen eingeschlafen wir
hatten da es war
überhaupt man musste in den Häusern
leben elbestan liegt hoch im Gebirge
erst heute kam Hilfe am dritten Tag nach
dem Beben
ist gleich doppelt betroffen denn hier
lag das Epizentrum des zweiten großen
Bebens mit einer Stärke von 7,6 auch
deswegen sind die Zerstörungen hier
besonders schlimm zunächst mussten die
Menschen hier auf sich allein gestellt
mit bloßen Händen die Opfer ausgraben
inzwischen sind Helfer und Freiwillige
aus allen Teilen des Landes gekommen
aber immer noch fehlt es an schwerem
Gerät das ist kaum über die vereisten
straßenschaft die Helfer geben die
Hoffnung aber noch nicht auf
wir haben gestern bis 4 Uhr nachts
gearbeitet und wir machen weiter gehen
bis ans Ende unserer Kräfte
in diesem Gebäude wohnten hauptsächlich
geflüchtete aus Syrien vor einigen
Stunden hörte man auch hier noch
Hilferufe aus dem Schutt sie sind jetzt
verstummt die Leiche eines 46-jährigen
wird geborgen sie bleibt auf der Straße
liegen die Retter müssen weitermachen
für die Toten gibt es nicht einmal
genügend Leichensäcke
die Opferzahlen sind auch deshalb so
hoch weil die Beben eine riesige Fläche
trafen in etwa so groß wie Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg zusammen teils dicht
besiedelt auf türkischer Seite gibt es
allein mehrere Millionenmetropolen wie
aderna oder Chanel Urfa dazu zahlreiche
Großstädte wie adiamant mit mehr als
600.000 Einwohnern dort beginnt der
Bericht von Alexandra Vacano
47 Stunden nach dem Erdbeben und sie
finden den dreijährigen Muhammed
willkommen zurück mein Schatz sagen die
türkischen Retter Wink in die Kamera und
sagt dass du okay bist jetzt holen wir
deine Mutter die sie kurz danach lebend
bergen können
halte durch nasser so ein spanisches
Rettungsteam auch hier in adiaman die
internationale Hilfe ist groß
Rettern aus Israel gelingt es zwei
Menschen aus den Ruinen ihres Hauses zu
befreien großer Jubel
[Applaus]
aber für viele tausende kommt die Hilfe
zu spät in dieser Sporthalle in
karaman-marash Leiche an Leiche
Angehörige die um Ihre Liebsten Wein
oder sie draußen noch suchen
sie trauern trösten sich wärmen sich am
Feuer zwischen den Trümmern ihrer
Millionenmetropole immerhin gibt es
jetzt etwas zu essen und zu trinken
unser Zuhause ist weg wir sind in den
Regen geraten wir schlafen auf nassen
Boden wir haben nicht einmal einen
heißen Tee zu trinken
und auch hier kommt langsam Hilfe an
Decken Kleidung für die Menschen in
Antakya 400.000 leben hier
sie müssen die Menschen aus den Städten
evakuieren sie können hier nicht wohnen
gerade bei dieser Kälte ist es nicht
möglich hier zu leben
Verzweiflung auch in Syrien sie tragen
ihre Angehörigen zugraben tausende Tote
auch hier
300.000 hätten ihr Obdach verloren
melden die Staatsmedien für das vom
Assad Regime kontrollierte Gebiet läuft
jetzt internationale Hilfe an etwa mit
Hilfsgütern aus Pakistan und
Rettungstrupps aus Russland
Tag 3 nach dem Beben allmählich wird das
Ausmaß der Katastrophe deutlich wie hier
in der Türkei in Karaman Maras
in currican in der Provinz hathai sind
fast alle Häuser einsturzgefährdet seit
gestern dort vor Ort ein Rettungsteam
mit spürhuten von Isa Germany wirkt ja
apokalyptisch weil es einfach zu groß
ist und zu viel wir versuchen an allen
Ecken und Enden was zu tun kriegen auch
immer wieder wir müssen gar nicht viel
suchen immer wieder kommen Menschen auf
uns zu bitten uns das geholfen wird weil
man überall Stimmen hört drei Menschen
konnte das Team von Isa seit gestern
schon das Leben retten
genau dort in kirikan ist seit gestern
Anselm Stern mit den Rettungskräften aus
Deutschland unterwegs an seinem wie
erlebst du die Situation wie kommen die
Helfer voran
ja Barbara die Situation hier vor Ort
die ist wirklich schlimm das kann man
nicht anders sagen die ist schrecklich
für die Menschen hier die Zerstörungen
die sind einfach wirklich gewaltig es
gibt keinen Strom es gibt kein Abwasser
es gibt keine Heizung und es ist nachts
hier wirklich bitterkalt und windig und
es geht bei den allermeisten Menschen
hier eigentlich nur noch Verzweiflung
über diese Situation und natürlich über
die vielen Toten und über die vielen
schwer verletzten die deutschen Retter
mit denen wir hier unterwegs sind die
geben wirklich alles viele von ihnen
haben seit zwei Tagen nicht mehr
geschlafen Arbeiten im zwei
Schichtbetrieb und sie versuchen immer
noch heute den ganzen Tag schon und
weiter immer noch einer Frau hier hinter
mir das Leben zu retten sie ist
eingeklemmt in diesem riesengroßen
Trümmerhaufen das war einmal ein fünf
stückiges Gebäude jetzt ist es eben nur
noch ein Trümmerhaufen und dieser
Trümmerhaufen der bewegt sich teilweise
auch immer noch also ist es völlig offen
ob die Rettung gelingt ob man dieser
Frau wirklich eben das Leben retten kann
das ist ein brandgefährlicher Einsatz es
gibt immer noch
Beben wie gehen die Helfer damit um
das ist ihnen absolut bewusst aber man
muss auch sagen sie sind darauf
vorbereitet sie arbeiten absolut
professionell sind etwa 40 Mann die hier
vor Ort sind sie haben sieben Spürhunde
dabei und das sind auch sozusagen super
eingespielte Pärchen Hundehalter Hunde
die teilweise seit vielen vielen Jahren
zusammenarbeiten teilweise einmal die
Woche regelmäßig trainieren also die
Gefahr ist Ihnen bewusst aber sie sind
darauf vorbereitet klar ist aber auch
sie riskieren hier ihr Leben um Leben zu
retten danke an seinem Stern danke und
alles Gute
das Gespräch haben wir aus technischen
Gründen aufgezeichnet mittlerweile wird
auch Kritik lauter warum läuft die Hilfe
mancherorts so langsam an warum hat die
Regierung nicht für erdbebensichere
Gebäude gesorgt Präsident erdogan ist
seit 20 Jahren an der Macht und will im
Mai wiedergewählt werden heute war er im
Katastrophengebiet Jörg Brase
viel zu lange habe es gedauert bis die
Hilfe kam bis Rettungskräfte in großer
Zahl vor Ort waren so lautet die Kritik
auch an ihm dem Präsidenten Tag 3 nach
dem großen Beben Recep Tayyip Erdogan
besucht Karaman Maras und wehrt sich
gegen die Vorwürfe
alle staatlichen Institutionen arbeiten
jetzt am ersten Tag gab es einige
Probleme aber am zweiten Tag und auch
heute haben wir die Situation unter
Kontrolle
Oppositionsführer Kemal Kilic storolo
sieht das anders wirft der Regierung
Versagen vor kilica Rolo reiste
ebenfalls durch die Krisenregion ist
bestürzt über die Schäden und gibt dem
Präsidenten eine mit Schuld
es gibt nur einen der für diese
Katastrophe verantwortlich ist und das
ist Erdogan 20 Jahre lang hat er es
versäumt das Land auf Erdbeben
vorzubereiten
Erdbebenforscher sehen das ähnlich
solche Bilder dürfte es nicht geben
wären Häuser erdbebensicher gebaut
worden doch Korruption und Ignoranz
hätten das verhindert meint der Geologe
so hätten Kollegen schon vor langer Zeit
eine Gefährdungskarte für Karaman Marash
gezeichnet wir haben diese Karte an
Herrn Bürgermeister geschickt die
Bürgermeister hat das angeguckt der hat
gesagt das nicht gemacht
woher fand diese man diese Autorität zu
sagen dass er das nicht glaubt
die Türkei sitze auf einem Pulverfass
mein Schenker alle wüssten das doch
getan werde viel zu wenig
trotz aller Kritik in der Türkei läuft
die Hilfe nach und nach an nicht so in
Syrien zerstörte Straßen geschlossene
Grenzen und die politische Lage in den
Bürgerkriegsland machen Hilfslieferungen
von außen schwer hier in Deutschland
sammeln Initiativen Geld mit dem in
Syrien dann das Nötigste beschafft
werden soll Cornelia Strauss berichtet
auf seinem Handy verfolgt der Syrer
Abdel rasack was in seiner Heimat
passiert Sekunden bevor ihr Haus in
jüngeres einstürzte konnten seine Eltern
und sein Bruder sich ins Freie retten
seine Hände zittern wenn er davon
erzählt 70% der Gebäude im Ort sind
eingestürzt mindestens 800 Menschen
werden vermisst Hilfe von außen ist dort
bisher nicht angekommen
wir brauchen jetzt professionelle
Ausrüstung spezielles Werkzeug mit dem
man Menschen aus Trümmern befreien kann
im Moment versuchen die Leute mit dem
was sie haben andere auszugraben während
die Hilfe im Erdbebengebiete Türkei
ankommt ist die Region jenseits der
Grenze von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten
Grund dafür ist die komplizierte
machtpolitische Situation im
Bürgerkriegsland Syrien wie schwierig es
ist die Region hinter der türkischen
Grenze zu erreichen wissen die
Mitarbeiter vom Verein dr Revolution
beim Versuch die Kollegin vor Ort zu
erreichen reist die Verbindung immer
wieder ab seit zwölf Jahren setzt sich
die Organisation für Demokratie in
Syrien ein dank dieser Arbeit kann sie
nun auf ein Netzwerk von Helfern in der
Region zurückgreifen das Team in Berlin
sammelt Spendengelder von dem
Mitarbeiterinnen wie SWAT Assad
notwendige Dinge kaufen sie meinte jetzt
langsam kommen halt Sachen rein aber von
händlernen die das halt einfach
verkaufen während halt unhilfen nicht
dort ankommen und die UN sagt wir können
das logistisch nicht gerade einrichten
ob technisches Werkzeug oder
Lebensmittel alle hoffen dass
internationale Unterstützung in der
Region so schnell wie möglich ankommen
kann
warum ist es in Syrien so schwer Hilfe
zu den Opfern zu bringen das beleuchtet
auch ZDF heute live um viertel vor acht
zu sehen in unserer App oder auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen und direkt im
Anschluss an diese Sendung sehen sie ein
zdf-spezial
und wenn Sie helfen möchten können Sie
spenden beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die IBAN
de65-100-400-600-1400 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien alle
Informationen gibt es auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
Anteilnahme auch heute im Bundestag mit
einer Schweigeminute gedachten die
Abgeordneten der Erdbebenopfer
Bundeskanzler scholz sagte weitere
Hilfen zu in seiner Regierungserklärung
vor dem eu-gipfelmorgen gegen Scholz
auch auf seine Ukraine Politik ein und
warnte vor einem so wörtlich
Überbietungswettbewerb bei
Waffenlieferungen das schade der
Geschlossenheit des Bündnisses CDU-Chef
Merz war Scholz Zögerlichkeit bei der
Unterstützung der Ukraine vor
am Abend dann trifft Scholz in Paris den
ukrainischen Präsidenten denn selensky
ist auf Europa Reise bei den größten
Unterstützern tagsüber war er in London
und bat dort eindringlich um
Kampfflugzeuge eine Lieferung von
Kampfjets hat Großbritannien nicht
zugesagt aber die Ausbildung von
ukrainischen Piloten Heike Petersen
berichtet
Überraschungsbesuch bei Freunden mit
Umarmung auf dem Rollfeld in Stansted
der britische Premier sunak und
Präsident selenski er wird heute immer
wieder Danke sagen für Unterstützung von
Anfang an und Downing Street gibt
bekannt Großbritannien wird jetzt sogar
ukrainische Kampfpiloten ausbilden damit
die in Zukunft auch NATO Jets fliegen
könnten lange umstritten
in Westminster Hall das ganze Parlament
versammelt
für eine emotionale selensky-rede
s an habt ihr Großbritannien eure
helfende Hand gereicht während die Welt
noch nicht begriffen hatte was sie tun
sollte
der echte Pilotenhelm als Geschenk
sollte lenskis üblicher Forderung nach
Kampfjets von den Verbündeten noch mehr
Kraft verleihen das britische
Verteidigungsministerium prüft
inzwischen objets verfügbar sind
danke an alle im voraus für kraftvolle
englische Flugzeuge Englisch
Großbritannien bildet bereits 10.000
Ukraine an Challenger 2 Panzern aus
silency und sunak waren heute beim
Training dabei König Charles empfängt
selensky im Buckingham Palast der sah ja
ein Air Force Pilot sagt selenski zuvor
daheim in der Ukraine sei jeder
Kampfpilot ein König
nun warten der französische Präsident
und der deutsche Kanzler auf selensky
und zwar in Paris
war russlands Präsident Putin direkt
oder indirekt verantwortlich für den
Abschuss der
Passagierflugzeugs mh17 über der
Ostukraine im Juli 2014 dafür gebe es
Anzeichen sagen internationale Ermittler
zwar existiere kein Beweis dafür dass er
den abschussbefohlen habe aber abgehörte
Telefongespräche ließen darauf schließen
das Putin persönlich die Lieferung der
Boden luftraketen an die Separatisten
genehmigt habe für eine Strafverfolgung
reiche das aber nicht aus
US-Präsident beiden hat der Ukraine noch
mal volle Rückendeckung zugesagt bei
seiner Rede zur Lage der Nation vor dem
US-Kongress versprach er Unterstützung
für die Ukraine solange es nötig sei in
seiner Ansprache forderte er die
Republikaner zur Zusammenarbeit auf um
Amerika zu einem ob er eine zweite
Amtszeit anstrebt das lies beiden weiter
offen
es ist die Zeit Lehren zu ziehen aus der
corona-pandemie Fehler wurden benannt
die Schulen waren zu lange zu die
Bedürfnisse der Kinder hatten keine
Priorität die Regierung will jetzt
gegensteuern um Langzeitfolgen zu
verhindern da geht es um soziale Folgen
bei Kindern aus ärmeren Familien aber
auch um gesundheitliche bei Jugendlichen
die an
long-buchholz berichtet
die corona-zeit hat Spuren hinterlassen
für erschreckend viele Kinder und
Jugendliche Amanda Zaus ist eine von
denen die bis heute leiden nach einer
corona-infektion vor über einem Jahr
bekommt die 16-jährige noch immer kaum
Luft deswegen voller Wäschekorb auf der
Brust ein engelgefühl bekommt ziemlich
schnell Kopfschmerzen und könnte mich
jetzt schon wieder hinlegen eigentlich
ich bin jetzt eigentlich schon wieder
müde doch auch die Einschränkungen
machten viele krank erst die langen
Schulschließungen Kontaktsperren
maskenpflicht die Zahlen schockieren
gerade bei Mädchen zwischen 15 und 17
Jahren stiegen die Essstörung um 54%
Depression um 18 % und die
Angststörungen um 24% der
Gesundheitsminister sieht die langen
Schulschließungen als Fehler an nun will
die Politik helfen vor allem mit Geld
und Personal
das schulden wir den Kindern aber wir
werden weiter alles tun was wir können
um das Behandlungsangebot für die Kinder
auszubauen und für uns im
Bundesgesundheitsministerium geht schon
seit Monaten die Gesundheit von Kindern
hat Vorrang deshalb sollen den
Krankenhäusern die Kinderstation
Priorität bekommen außerdem sollen Kitas
Plätze und Personal ausbauen Schulen
mental health Coaches bekommen also
Gesundheitsberater und die Jugendämter
mehr psychosoziale Beratung anbieten
viele junge Menschen haben den Eindruck
dass Ihre Anliegen zu wenig von der
Politik und zu wenig von der
Gesellschaft wahrgenommen werden und das
müssen wir ändern ändern soll sich
vieles doch ob all das die schweren
Folgen der Pandemie wirklich abmildern
kann wird sich zeigen
und jetzt Biathlon WM in Oberhof der
Auftrag fürs deutsche Team lief nicht
wirklich gut ja nur Platz sechs in der
Mixed-Staffel da hatte man zum Beginn
der Heimweh im durchaus mit einem
Podestplatz geliebäugelt aber erst
platzte Lokal matadorin Vanessa Vogt und
dann verpasste Benedikt doll beim
Schießen endgültig ein deutscher Erfolg
ein holpriger Stab für das deutsche
mix-team starliferin Vanessa Vogt wirkt
nach dem Strauchler zu Beginn nervös
braucht liegend und auch stehend
14 in Führung zu diesem Zeitpunkt
Frankreich mit Denise Hermann Wick
beginnt die auf Deutschland nach der
Hälfte des Rennens auf einem Podestplatz
Rang drei hinter Italien und Frankreich
der dritte Läufer Benny doll geht ein
hohes Tempo auf der Runde und hat
Probleme beim Schießen Strafrunde für
Deutschland das Podest somit außer
Reichweite die Norweger gewinnen trotz
einer straf Runde diese mix-staffel vor
Italien und Frankreich
Schlussläufer Roman Rees zeigt ein gutes
Rennen kann nur Ergebnis Kosmetik
bleiben Platz 6 zum Auftakt dieser WM
zum Fußball hoffenheim hat Ex
vfb-chefcoach peligrine matarazzo als
neuen Trainer verpflichtet erlöst
erfolgt André Breitenreiter der am
Montag beurlaubt worden war ja die TSG
im Abstiegskampf die Eintracht dagegen
weiter auf Erfolgskurs auch gestern
Abend im DFB-Pokal im Achtelfinale
besiegten die Frankfurter Darmstadt 98
hier der Treffer von Eintracht Stürmer
kolomani zum 4:2 Endstand ein packendes
Hessenderby bei dem sich erst und
Zweitligisten lange Zeit auf Augenhöhe
begegnen
ja und noch ein Pokal Derby heute Abend
im Revier der VfL empfängt den BVB Sven
Voss in Bochum ja das dürfte doch sehr
unterhaltsam werden oder
ja Norbert wir erwarten vor allem einen
sehr sehr stimmungsvollen Abend hier in
Bochum auch wenn sich die Bochumer Fans
hier auf der Osttribüne noch
zurückhalten und ihre Stimme schon aber
erstens befinden sich ja noch viele
draußen außerhalb des Stadions zum
zweitens wurde das Grönemeyer Bochum
Lied ja noch nicht angespielt dazu
später aber der Dortmunder Bus ist schon
da die Gäste haben ja nicht so eine
lange Anfahrt nur etwa 20 Minuten hat
Hummels der erste der raus kam ansonsten
ist Borussia Dortmund der klare Favorit
heute 4 Siege in 20 23 die Mannschaft
hatten Lauf aber Achtung der VfL Bochum
hat die heimstarke die letzten fünf
Heimspiele hier im ruhestadion gewonnen
das wird ein spannendes Spiel
atmosphärisch genauso wie sportlich um
20:25 sehen wir uns wieder wenn danke
und alle Höhepunkte des spielt später
auch auf heute.de und in der heute App
danke schön bitteschön noch Lotto
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 8 14 17 21 39 44
und die Superzahl 9 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
das Wetter bringt morgen ein bisschen
Regen und viel Sonne Details hat gleich
Katja Hornissen das heute journal mit
Christian Sievers in der Halbzeitpause
gegen halb zehn jetzt geht es weiter mit
dem Spezial zum Erdbeben ihnen wünschen
wir einen schönen Abend und bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das ist wirklich
ungewöhnlich dass sie zielen mal die
gleichen Temperaturen meldet wie die
norwegische Küste mit 10 Grad jetzt
ändert sich das Wetter das liegt an
diesem Wolken die von Nordwesten
heranziehen das bemerken wir schon heute
Nacht meist aber ist es klar selten
bildet sich etwas Nebel oder Dunst und
die Temperaturen sinken auf null bis
minus 15 Grad morgen Vormittag sieht
dieses Wolkenband weiter nach Südosten
es kann in Schleswig-Holstein etwas
regnen für die meisten beginnt der Tag
aber mit sehr viel Sonnenschein selten
stört Nebel oder Dunst der löst sich
dann bis zum Nachmittag auf dieses
wolkenbahn sieht etwas weiter nach
Südosten bringt ganz wenig Regen mit und
an der Nordseeküste kann sich dann schon
wieder die Sonne zeigen die höchste
Temperaturen liegen Morgen meist bei 0
bis 4 Grad ganz im Westen sind es so
sechs oder sieben Grad und in den
nächsten Tagen ist es im Norden und
Nordosten etwas unbeständiger sonst
dominiert noch das ruhige Winterwetter
guten Abend